[Music]
we're going to start off with marcia who
joins us in atlanta georgia marcia how
can we help
oh
thanks for taking my call you bet
um my husband and i um
have been working the ranchi plan about
two years ago and
we sold our home and we paid off over
140 000 worth of credit card bills wow
140 000 in credit card bills
yes my husband was
uh i guess he was just caught up in uh
trying to get
extra cards to pay you know and transfer
uh
balances and just got caught up in a lot
of credit card names what was he buying
well we had we were uh you could call it
living the vita local uh
but you know what matters marcia is that
you guys got on the same page and paid
this off that's unbelievable
yes we did well now
yeah we are in a situation um that i
really need some help with
we have
over 300 300 000 worth of student loans
between myself and him
and we have
five investment properties three we own
outright and two we have a mortgage on
and
you know we're thinking should we sell
uh
investment properties to just get this
student loan
out of our lives that's the only
debt that we have now or should we
continue to rent these properties and
just use our income to pay off the
student loans what is your household
income
our household income is about 200 000
okay
great income there
and you've got 300 000 student loans
making 200 i mean if you wanted to if
you wanted to get intense you can just
use your income and pay off these
student loans now if i'm in your shoes
and i've got five rental properties uh
two of them having a mortgage on them i
want you to be completely debt free as
soon as possible so if i'm you i'm
selling one or two of those mortgage pro
properties to pay off these loans what
are these properties worth
well um
they were they're both worth about 200
000 but one of i mean we paid dirt cheap
for them like 20 000 so
well
the mortgage for all the mortgage
properties sorry um the mortgage
property probably about 250 000 and one
is worth 200 thousand what do you owe
what do you owe on each
on on the one that's worth
two hundred thousand we owe sixty eight
thousand on that one
and the other one we owe
123.
wow
so there's your answer i'm hearing if
you sell the two with the mortgage on
them you could pretty much be debt free
like tomorrow
yes and you still have three paid for
properties
right i put a ha i put a sign in the
yard of both of those two that you have
a mortgage on today
oh that that that is good yes that's
what i was thinking that's what i
thought you all would say
well you are thinking properly
i'm glad we could give you some
confirmation there well you guys have
done really well on that side i think
you were just doing some things out of
order and now once you pay off these
student loans you've got three paid for
properties you're gonna really build
some wealth and my take is that you're
going to buy your next properties with
cash
yeah most definitely that's what we're
thinking i love it well you guys have
done really well we're cheering for you
get rid of these properties get rid of
these student loans way to go marcia and
you know what's great uh you could hear
the husband in the background like
they're all in yeah and you know what i
really loved about that call when we
first you know started talking to her
and you asked
what was the debt they paid off like 140
000 and credit card debt and you were
like what was it and she was like
my husband and it was so sweet in that
he was completely off the reservation
and somewhere in that story we didn't
get it they got on the same page yeah
and paid off 140 000 with a credit card
debt and now look at them
is clear they're doing they're willing
to do whatever it takes even though
they've made some mistakes they're
they're owning up and going we don't
want to live this way anymore we're done
live in la vida loca oh yeah that's what
was great that was the life that needs
to decide we're done live in la vida
loca it's smoke and mirrors it's a house
of cards yeah you know what i'm
embarrassed to say i don't actually know
what that means okay ken i'm translated
yes you are very popular ricky martin
song back in the late 90s early 20s
i am embarrassed to say i forgot i it
felt familiar to me but i was like i
can't place it i'm wanting to sing it on
air but i think the fcc might shut us
down oh we don't want to do that i want
all the license for a lot of reasons
what does it mean though
uh it means living living the crazy life
oh thank you for living the good life
you know
i didn't right no i didn't know they're
laughing at me in the control room i
don't mind okay i just taught you some
spanish ken i feel pretty good i feel a
little bit more valuable who says you
can't teach an old dog new tricks
well you know i would take offense of
that but compared to you george i am the
old dog and i might as well just own it